federal health officials are one step
closer to approving the pfizer
coronavirus vaccine for children ages 5
to 11 years old next week an advisory
panel for the cdc will meet to make
their decision on the smaller dose after
the food and drug administration on
friday offered its approval for
emergency use this could be the
long-awaited protection that millions of
parents have been waiting for in the
pandemic michael george is here with the
details michael good morning dana good
morning the pfizer children's vaccine is
about a third of the adult dose but a
clinical trial found it was nearly 91
percent effective at preventing covet if
it gets final cdc approval next week
some 28 million children will be
eligible for shots
with the prospect of widespread
vaccinations for children looming food
and drug administration commissioner dr
janet woodcock is assuring parents the
shots are safe
vaccinating younger children against
covid19 will bring us closer to
returning to a sense of normalcy parents
and guardians can rest assured that we
conducted a comprehensive and rigorous
evaluation of the data on the vaccine
safety and effectiveness and that this
vaccine meets our high standards but
vaccinations for young children could be
contentious as they've been with adults
a cbs news yougov poll this month showed
a near even split among parents 37
percent said yes to vaccinations 35 said
no and 26 percent were in the maybe
category after jay got the shot i was
just completely
relieved rachel baker's 10 year old son
took part in the clinical trial when we
realized that even if we were to
contract it it'd be very unlikely that
we'd have anything severe for adults
working for new york city vaccination
clinics were unusually busy yesterday
there thousands of police and
firefighters face losing their jobs if
they report to work monday unvaccinated
or don't have a religious or health
exemption as we're reaching this
deadline we're going to see a lot of
what we saw with department education
with health and hospitals that people do
what's necessary and get vaccinated in
chicago all city workers must disclose
their vaccination status after the city
council yesterday enforced the directive
from the mayor and a court backed it up
we've got to take the drama
and the politics out of this but a new
study by the kaiser family foundation
found more than a third of unvaccinated
workers say they'd leave their job if
their employer required them to get a
vaccine or get tested weekly all this
comes as the daily rate of covet
infections continued to drop this week
on average more than 70 000 people a day
tested positive for the virus and
tragically an average of 1300 people
died each day
most of them unvaccinated
and a new study from the cdc shows
vaccines give much better protection
than natural immunity unvaccinated
people who recovered from covid are
actually five times more likely to get
infected again than people who got the
pfizer or moderna vaccine michelle good
point michael thank you so much